Welcome.
This course is for anyone pointing a software-defined radio at the sky — scanner listeners, new hams, tinkerers with a
thirty-dollar dongle — and for anyone who's ever nodded along to "megahertz" without being totally sure what it measures.
No math beyond arithmetic, no
prerequisites.
Just the mental models underneath every antenna,
every waterfall display, and every decode.
Six chapters, each one idea.
First, the radio wave itself — what's
actually rippling.
Then frequency, the address every signal
lives at.
Then modulation — how a wave is made to
carry a message.
Then bandwidth, the width of the road it
drives on.
And finally the measuring tools: the decibel, radio's own arithmetic,
and signal-to-noise ratio, the number that decides everything.
Every chapter stands alone, and each one matches a written Field Guide article at gophertrunk
dot org — linked below, chapter by chapter, if you want the formulas and the sources.
Skip freely.
But watched in order, each idea hands off
to the next.
Let's start with the ripple itself.